you've written a new album this is walk
around the moon the title track yeah I
like this vocal
ah I found a stranger
this is about now I don't know if this
is true you can confirm it but it's
about eating mushrooms you do mushrooms
yeah I do sometimes yes where are you at
with drugs you'll do weed you'll do
mushrooms where are you at I don't do a
lot of any drugs at the moment I mean
are mushrooms drugs I suppose they are
they are like they are a controlled
substance seems like everybody does them
yeah I think they're pretty good for you
um I mean they're good for me if you
have too many of them you you shouldn't
operate a vehicle but uh but it's a good
time to you know take a walk in the
woods and I'm also at a point in my life
where I think I can take a you know a
few mushrooms and then just not be
worried about anything so it was part of
the process when you were writing this
the mushrooms made you feel creative
this uh inspired you yeah and it was
also like
um there were some mushrooms and there
was a pandemic and it was and it was
like well you know if not now when you
know might as well you know who knows
who's coming out of the forest we should
probably do these mushrooms who doesn't
love a song written on mushrooms that's
a sales pitch
foreign